A show's villain is as important as its hero, but
that doesn't mean we always know who the bad guy
is right away. Here’s a spoiler-filled
list of the best bad guy in TV history.
When "Lost" arrived in 2004, there wasn't much
like it on the small screen. It featured an
enormous cast and brought over 18 million
viewers to ABC — the highest ratings for an
offering on the network in almost four years.
One thing the show didn't have, however,
was an honest-to-goodness villain.
The survivors of downed Oceanic Flight 815 had
to weather some pretty singular adversities.
There was the smoke monster, of course, and the
everlasting conflict between anti-hero Sawyer
and, well, everyone else. But "Lost" was
missing a true big bad. All that changed,
however, when actor Michael Emerson showed
up as the mysterious Henry Gale in Season 2.
Some of the members of the group felt Henry's
stories about arriving on the island in a
hot-air balloon, and losing his wife in the
subsequent crash, were a bit too neat to be true.
So in the Season 2 episode "Lockdown," the Oceanic
survivors go looking for answers. They find a
balloon and a grave, but Henry's wife isn't in it
— the real Henry is. When the phony Gale is called
out for the falsehood, Emerson really shines
in the role. He seems to morph into an entirely
different person, Ben Linus, in the blink of an
eye. This manipulative antagonist would go on
to wreak havoc on the island in the following
seasons, finally giving "Lost" a true villain.
The inaugural season of "True Detective"
follows two investigators — played by Matthew
McConaughey [muh-KAH-nuh-hay] and Woody Harrelson
— on the hunt for a serial killer. Throughout the
season, the show's writer and director expertly
build the expectation of the evil we'll encounter
when we meet our villain. The protagonists'
escalating run-ins with voodoo, kidnapping
cover-ups, and violent meth dealers signal that
whatever is waiting at the end won't be pretty.
At the end of Season 1 Episode 7, audiences
are finally clued into the killer's identity,
and it's an almost forgettable
groundskeeper from way back in Episode 3.
In the hands of a lesser creative team, the
moment might've felt like a lazy callback.
Not so here. By the time deranged killer
Errol Childress [AIR-uhl CHILL-driss] appears,
casually giving two other police
officers directions from his lawn mower,
viewers have witnessed a laundry list of evil
deeds. The dread of confronting something much
worse than what the two leads have previously
encountered is as thick as Louisiana's humidity.
As Errol watches the police officers drive
off and the creepy music starts to play,
we see scars on the lower part of his face
consistent with descriptions of a suspect.
Revelatory moments like this one really marked
the slow-burning 1st season of "True Detective"
for greatness. The closing moments of "After
You've Gone" dare the audience to keep watching,
and almost make viewers hope Harrelson
and McConaughney stay at home.
“Stop. Really, man. Stop. I don’t wanna hear it.”
For much of "The Flash" Season 1,
Harrison Wells acts as the kindly,
genius founder of S.T.A.R. [“star”] Labs. He
supports Barry Allen's efforts as a superhero
and serves as his mentor. Over the course of
the season, however, his character begins to
act increasingly strange, and Flash and his
respective allies suspect something is off.
A stinger in Episode 9 shows the audience
that Harrison is in possession of
Reverse Flash's iconic suit, but the show
doesn't confirm the worst until Episode 15.
By that point, most of Team Flash suspect Wells
is the yellow speedster, but not everyone is
convinced. Unfortunately, Wells' surrogate
son Cisco [SIS-coh] finds out the hard way.
After Cisco discovers where Wells
hides the suit in the previous episode,
Wells confronts him, admitting that he not
only had a hand in Barry's mother's death but
is actually Eobard [EE-oh-bard] Thawne — Flash's
all-time big bad. Anyone wondering why Wells might
announce his secrets so bluntly gets their answer
when Wells follows his monologue by killing Cisco.
This moment, where Thawne admits his sins and
kills a character his alter ego cared about,
cements the villain's full arrival and the scope
of his malevolence. And it happened in the 1st
episode back from the show's mid-season break,
giving fans a compelling reason to keep tuning in.
Marvel's "WandaVision" kicks off when the
Scarlet Witch finds herself married to a
newly-risen Vision in an idyllic, sitcom-style
existence. Viewers watch as Wanda tries to
embrace her new life, but slowly discovers
something's amiss. All isn't what it appears
to be in Wanda's primetime network town,
especially when it comes to her neighbors.
Throughout the series, Wanda has kooky and
friendly encounters with a neighbor named
Agnes [AG-ness], played by a scenery-chewing
Kathryn Hahn. Like any sitcom neighbor,
she's a bit snoopy, but mostly kind
— until the end of Episode 7. While
Wanda takes a day to recharge, Agnes
looks after her children. Soon, though,
Wanda suspects she and her family are
in danger and goes to collect her kids.
“Where are the twins?”
Agnes tells Wanda the kids are playing in
the basement. When Wanda descends the stairs,
she finds a witch's lair. Agnes then
walks into the room and introduces
herself as a fellow witch named
Agatha [AG-uh-thuh] Harkness.
As Agnes invades Wanda's mind, the show
suddenly cuts to the song "Agatha All Along."
In one catchy tune, Agatha is revealed to have
been pulling Wanda's strings throughout the whole
series — and worse, she killed Wanda's dog. The
number is a great showcase for Hahn's charisma and
enormously raises the stakes for the coming
series climax by introducing the main antagonist.
Who needs subtle reveals?
More theme songs, please.
When "Westworld" first premiered in 2016, its
robo-cowboy worldbuilding and unique storytelling
made it must-see TV. As the show confidently
swaggered through its time-bending opening season,
it delivered twist after twist. One of the most
devastating was the finale's bad guy reveal.
In the show's premiere, audiences are
introduced to Jimmi Simpson's William
and Ed Harris' Man in Black. On first impressions,
the two stand in stark contrast to one another.
William is a meek but kind first-timer in
the theme park, and the Man in Black is a
park veteran who revels in doing horrible things
to its animatronic hosts. As the series unfolds,
it becomes clear that the show's story is
set in two distinct timelines. However,
since "Westworld" was co-created by Jonathan
Nolan, brother and collaborator to the notoriously
confusing director Christopher Nolan, it's not
always clear exactly which timeline is which.
The show sets the record straight when
its protagonist, robotic host Dolores,
played by Evan Rachel Wood, encounters
the Man in Black in the series finale.
He reveals that they've met before and that
his first encounter with Dolores helped him
find himself. Dolores remembers who he is,
calling him William, and the editors intercut
his monologue with sequences that show the
once-gentle William becoming the evil man he
is now. It's tragic that someone so kind
could wind up so vile. But in a pivotal
moment to the show, his gutting reveal clearly
establishes what's present and what's past.
Not many detective shows leave audiences
as shaken as "Broadchurch" did,
and all of that is due to its villain
reveal. In the show, detectives Ellie
Miller and Alec Hardy are investigating
the murder of 11-year-old named Danny.
Like most detective shows, in the
end, the partners get their man,
but by time it's over audiences and
protagonists alike will wish the
villain had never been revealed. The show
builds up our trust in relationships by
dedicating notable attention to the supportive
relationship between Ellie and her husband Joe.
So in the end, when Hardy discovers Ellie's
husband Joe is in possession of Danny's phone,
anybody watching prays it's a red herring.
But it's not. A flashback reveals that Joe
murdered Danny because Danny threatened to
expose their pedophilic affair to the town.
It's awful on so many levels and adds real
bite to the series' focus on trust and secrets.
The murder scene's frantic editing showcases
just how fast the threat of exposure escalates
things between Joe and his young victim. Once
they find out what happened, viewers sit with
turning stomachs waiting for Ellie to discover
her husband's secret. Only such a powerfully
depressing reveal can make the audience hope
one of the protagonists never learns the truth.
The HBO series "Watchmen" has a bad guy reveal
that is quite different from it’s graphic novel
bad guy reveal. When viewers first meet
Lady Trieu [TROO], she's a brilliant,
conglomerate-owning, clone-maintaining
scientist with a hidden agenda.
However, it's not clear just how dark
that agenda is until it's too late.
At first, the show's big bad appears to be an
organization called Cyclops [SYE-klahps], a
white supremacist group out to
steal Dr. Manhattan's powers.
However, when they attempt their plot in the
finale, their leader gets turned into a puddle,
and his followers are teleported away to find
Trieu waiting with an even larger evil plan.
Trieu reveals herself as the real puppet-master
and the daughter of Adrian Viedt [VITE], the
surprise villain in the comics. It's
brilliant because it not only connects
Trieu to a character from the source material,
but also connects their murderous motives.
In the comics, Adrian blew up Manhattan to
trick the world into agreeing to world peace.
In the HBO series, Trieu murders Dr. Manhattan
in an attempt to subjugate the world to her
benevolent will. The comic and TV series
are separated by decades of cultural change,
but the latter's villain reveal unites
their central questions about wielding
immense power over other people in the
service of a personal utopian vision.
Humanizing a murderer is tricky in any medium,
but Showtime's "Dexter" managed to do it for eight
seasons — and was eventually revived for a ninth.
The show's premise, that Dexter is a serial killer
who only kills other serial killers, is a strong
way to hook an audience. As the show goes on,
however, its elaborate twists and turns
prove it's more than just its engaging hook.
During Season 1, the show fleshes out Dexter's
healthy relationship with his adopted sister, Deb.
It also establishes a rivalry between himself
and a serial killer known only as the Ice
Truck Killer. So things get complicated
when the audience discovers that the man
courting Deb is actually — gasp
— the Ice Truck Killer himself.
In a reveal so casual it demands an immediate
re-watch, Deb discusses plans for a date with
her suitor Rudy. Rudy tells Deb he needs to
wrap up some housework before coming over.
After he hangs up the phone,
the audience gets a look at what
that work is — chopping and packing human
body parts in his walk-in murder freezer.
It's an impeccable dramatic irony. The viewers
know the truth about Rudy, but Deb and Dexter
remain in the dark — for a long time! For the
remainder of the season, the audience watches
Dexter and Deb inch closer to the truth — and the
danger, and the tension is tangible. "Dexter" is
engrossing entertainment, and moments like
these cement its place in great TV history.
The villain reveal at the end of
HBO's "Sharp Objects" is probably
the most audacious on this list, casting the
events of the entire show in a new light.
"Sharp Objects" is based on Gillian
Flynn's novel of the same name — yep,
the same author behind "Gone Girl," another story
with a shocking villain reveal. HBO's miniseries
follows crime reporter Camille Preaker as
she returns home to Wind Gap, Missouri.
There, she gets caught up investigating the
murders of some local girls. In between sleuthing,
she navigates her complex relationships with
her mother, Adora, and teen half-sister, Amma.
Ultimately, Camille discovers evidence suggesting
Adora killed the girls and sends her own mother
to prison. Bleak stuff. But this is a Gillian
Flynn story we're talking about. It can always
get a lot worse in the most unexpected ways,
and moments before the credits roll, it does.
Literally within the show's closing minutes,
Camille discovers evidence hidden in Amma's room
that suggests she was the killer all along. Amma
appears in the doorway, sees Camille, and whispers
"Don't tell Mama." The show hard-cuts to the
credits, but anyone trying to catch their breath
is acting too soon. A mid-credits scene shows Amma
definitively committing each murder, including
that of a new friend, Mae, some time later after
she and Camille move to St. Louis. It's brilliant
and possibly one of the most depressing
endings ever committed to the small screen.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.